right so how heavy was our flowchart for
stationary points and what I want to do
is map out for you you now know a lot of
information and enough information and
skills to actually make some choices for
example the key choice that I was
talking about just now is you now know
two ways to determine the nature of a
stationary point you can use the first
derivative you can use the second
derivative and whichever way you go
there are actually different things that
you have to do and there's a lot of
processes that have to be stuck in your
head so what I'm going to show you now
is it's quite a complicated flow chart
there's a lot of steps to it if it the
first moment you're like wow I'm quite
overwhelmed by how much there is here
don't fret with practice you'll become
familiar with the different steps and
the decisions you have to make but there
is no way to get around this okay if
you're a strong to unit student let
alone an extension student you have to
master this okay so give you some time
believe me you'll be doing it a fair bit
so you'll get quite good at it so on the
left hand side where we always begin is
with the original function so we start
with the original function and then if
we are being told that this is a
question to do with stationary points
then we know no matter what you're going
to have to find a first derivative right
so from your original function going
across the page by the way I'm trying to
do this like my PDF there writing on is
an a4 page so roughly try and do the
size of your page the size of mine
because otherwise you will run out of
space it's a lot to put on this you're
going to differentiate you're going to
find your first derivative so this is
the easy part we know we can sort of do
this on autopilot it's not really many
choices involved okay but then as soon
as this happens what are we searching
for on a on on the stationary points
we're looking for the first degree of to
be zero right so what we are looking for
is that derivative to be zero now anyone
who's actually constructed flowcharts
before say for software design and that
kind of thing knows that when there is a
choice of some kind you don't use a
rectangle you actually use a diamond so
I'm going to draw a little diamond to
you like sir okay
now one of two three
will happen you may find some places so
you'd expect most questions you will
find some places where the first
derivative is equal to zero so there's
going to be a yes branch that goes from
here however it's important to mention
that at the moment we're dealing with
like we're deliberately giving you
questions where there are stationary
points but that's not always the case so
it might be the fact that you don't find
any places where the first derivative is
equal to zero okay so therefore if that
happens that's really easy there are no
stationary points that's nice there are
lots of functions you're already
familiar with we just haven't learned to
differentiate them yet where this is the
case probably the easiest two are the
exponential and the log functions right
they never turn around they never stop
very no stationary point so when we
learn how to differentiate those you'll
find the derivative is never equal to
zero okay but in most cases yes you will
find a place or places where the first
derivative is zero so you can say at
that point stationary points they must
exist excuse me okay so at this point if
stationary points exists you found X
values right there but of course you
want the whole point it's very very
uncommon it does happen occasionally but
it's very uncommon that we just want the
x value a lot of students forget that
that's a thing that you need so remember
on your arm on your all of the
information you've written you've got to
go back to the original function and
you've got a substitute in those X
values to get a Y value now if all they
ask you to do is to find stationary
points and not determine any nature
you're done that's really nice this is
not too complicated so this part of the
diagram everything that we've just done
this is about finding stationary points
okay so if there's a really basic like a
question 11-time question where it's
like yeah look two marks max or let's
use Phi coordinates your Holman host
okay
however most of the time they actually
want you to do war so if you want to
find out more if you need more
information like if the question says
determine the nature of these stationary
points then this is where the fun begins
okay now remember I said to you all this
is choice we can get first derivative or
we can go secondary with you the big
question that I usually get asked is
well how do I know which one to do like
when do I choose one or the other there
is one key question that you need to ask
and that is the function that you've got
here's the function I'm doing it like
this because it's going to be in a
diamond in a second is the function easy
to differentiate or not is the function
easy to differentiate okay so this is a
choice it is worth pointing out that
sometimes this is a gray area right you
look at the function you're like oh I
could differentiate it'll be alright or
I could go the other way so this is a
genuine choice and there's a yes or no
answer
so at the moment the functions you've
been dealing with are all polynomials
that's all we know how to differentiate
at the moment those are really easy to
differentiate so I would say yes
function is easy to differentiate if
that's the case there's nothing stopping
you from differentiating again so
remember up here we looked at the first
derivative okay
now I'm going to go to the second
derivative so this is what we were just
looking at in the example before okay
we'll come back to that in a second what
happens after the second derivative if
of course it is not easier to
differentiate I don't write this down
it's quite easy to think of functions
you already know how to differentiate
that you're like I don't want to
differentiate that again here's an
example 4x minus 3 on X minus 2 you know
how to differentiate that what really
you're gonna use the question rule right
and when you use the question rule you
say that's you that's
what you get out of the quotient rule is
another question you get another
fraction and it gets worse in fact every
time you use the question wrong the
derivative gets more and more
complicated so while it's physically
possible after I get the first root of
that I probably don't really want to
find the second derivative okay because
it's just going to become an algebra
later disaster so if you say is the
function easier to differentiate no you
don't need to go to the second
derivative you go back to what we looked
at before which is your table of values
for the first derivative that's dy on DX
whoops
that should be a that should be a
diamond as well okay so this is the
first critical branch
and then from there you kind of okay
right let's go with the table guys
because we know how to do this we
establish this right one of three things
will happen that correspond to the three
different kinds of stationary points
you've got right scuse me so the first
thing that might happen is there is a
change of sign you're going to go for
all I'm going to use a color note you're
going to go for a positive to negative
so this is the first derivative yeah if
you're going from a positive first
derivative that's increasing to a
negative that's decreasing what kind of
stationary point do you have this is a
we're gonna shape you're gonna say this
is a maximum turning point look I'm at
the top at my stationary point okay so
if I find that this is the case over
here then I can draw this conclusion
because this is the ending I'm gonna put
this in green you know officially that
kind of thing you've got a maximum
turning point there you go I'm finished
right alternatively something else might
happen you might not go from positive to
negative you might have that in reverse
so if you went from negative to positive
this is decreasing stationery increasing
so what kind of turning point is that
that's a minimum so let's put that over
here so then I know that's what's
happening but of course there is one
last alternative because you don't have
to have a max or a min it could afterall
be a horizontal point inflection so what
does your table of values look like if
you do have a horizontal point of
inflection and the answer is there's no
change inside there's not positive to
negative or negative to positive you
have a consistent sign on both sides so
that's what I'm going to say consistent
sign positive to positive or negative to
negative so if you have a consistent
sign on either side of your stationary
point then you know cool it is a
horizontal point of inflection okay so I
told you it was a complicated flow chart
sorry we now have the entire thing
mapped out for if we went through the
first derivative we tested out the table
of values we drew the thing up and from
there we can say oh yeah it's a it's a
maximum it's a minimum or it's one of
these weird funky horizontal points of
inflection okay but of course the second
derivative is our other options so just
like we're looking for signed with the
first few who are looking for sign for
the secondary of just in a slightly
different way so in order to make sure I
have enough space I think I'm going to
try and go over let's try and do it this
way big I have enough room so we're
going to look for the individual value
of the second derivative it'll tell me
concave up concave down or not concave
at all okay so what I'm checking is the
sign of the second derivative d squared
Y on DX squared from here things are
going to branch out depending on the
sides so just like in the other cases
I'm going to draw myself a diamond over
here okay all right tell me what kind of
sign positive negative whatever will
give me a maximum think about it a
maximum is concave down so therefore
what would send
be over here to a maximum and the answer
is if you have a let's choose the right
color a negative second derivative okay
I'm using I'm using red for negative
before the other hand we are expecting a
minimum then it's not concave down it's
concave up so that means that the sign
of dy d squared is x squared is going to
be concave up means positive right so
positive ah so now we come to the last
one if you're neither negative nor
positive if you have a second derivative
that is exactly zero now what do we do
now what do we do well this is a bit of
a tricky one right we now have to go
back to just like we had a table of
values for the first derivative you
cannot avoid now if it's zero you don't
know what's going on right you remember
my X to the for example you know maybe
it's a horizontal point reflection but
maybe it's not so you need to test on
either side you need your table of
values but this time it's a table of
values for the second derivative so
because you're not sure what you're
going to get out of this there's a
choice I'm going to put my my diameter
here again okay all right so if you get
your table values right then a bunch of
different things will happen we already
know by the way that this is a
stationary point we're just trying to
work out what kind of a stationary point
it is okay so if it's a horizontal point
of inflection then the definition of a
point of inflection full-stop is that
there's a change in concavity remember
that okay so there is a change in sign
like this so what I'm going to do is
what might happen like this is that
there's a change in sign change in side
if you went from concave up to concave
down great horizontal point of
inflection or vice versa so that's nice
but I'm gonna choose a different color
here let's go for let's go for gray
hopefully you can see this if there is
not a change in sign okay like you know
X to the four concave up concave up so
what kind of a stationary point is that
if you're concave up and then concave up
that's a it's a minimum turning point
isn't it so you could go through here
over to a minimum depending on what you
get what if you tested on either side
and you got concave down concave down
that's a maximum so you could also come
over here right so the key is don't just
get lost in all the numbers think about
what it means there's a picture so now
let's have a look at this monstrous
thing let's see if I can get the whole
thing on the page like that there we go
okay so being that this is the first
time you've seen this I mean certainly
the first time I saw this the first time
I saw this I drew it and I was still
over world by I was like I made up this
thing okay um yes it is complicated but
that's because you are not familiar with
it yet but just like like tying your
shoelaces or or driving or something
like that he's made up of many processes
which as you become familiar with them
excuse me you'll become increasingly
comfortable with them I can tell you
right now a bad 5 or bad 6 2 units
student again not worrying about
extension a bad 5 or bad 6 2 decision is
reasonably comfortable with this process
because they are so well rehearsed with
it ok so it might look intimidating but
it will get into your head just remember
the critical spots there like think
about whether your functions is your
differentiate there's a key choice okay
think about the values that you get out
of that there's a key point of
interpretation on each of those ok does
anyone have any questions I'll leave
that there for a moment for you to take
in or maybe you want to snap a picture
to reduce the flush pipe and you've done
the first time I drew this it looked a
lot less I know you might think that's
overwhelm you know look a lot less
logical and I have a lot more
overlapping lines and that kind of
things so this is like version 5 or
something like that oh by the way
there's one thing
it's missing it's not something to add
on it's just something to help you
understand your I told you on this step
up here is find that's what you're doing
here what's all this about what are we
doing we're determining nature so maybe
you want to just lastly complete this by
say I have a big curly brace over here
all of this stuff over here is going to
be I'm gonna run it this upside down
hold on all of this stuff down here the
hard part really is what kind of a
stationary point is this is it of Max is
it a min is at a horizontal infliction
you've really got to think through
what's going on here that's where the
calculus really comes into its own okay